acclamé c'est ainsi que milos vistre si
les l'ensemble de sa délégation ont été
accueillis à taïwan le président du
sénat tchèque participe à un forum sur
le commerce et l'investissement
une visite informelle en l'absence de
relations diplomatiques officielles
entre les deux pays mais qui prend des
allures de plaidoyer politique
je crois que sont la possibilité du
libre coopération entre les
entrepreneurs et les employeurs il n'y
aura pas de liberté de démocratie en
république tchèque ou à taïwan
car la liberté et la démocratie sont la
base de la prospérité
sarah 40 passe par était un déplacement
qui est loin de plaire à la chine qui
considère taïwan comme l'une de ses
provinces et qui voient d'un mauvais
oeil la venue d'une délégation ayant
l'ambition de créer des contacts
politiques qui nuisent à sa souveraineté
pékin s'est clairement opposé à ce
déplacement et n'a pas hésité à mettre
en garde prague
nous condamnons fermement et sommes
sérieusement préoccupés par les actes
flagrant des forces cheikh anti
chinoises qui viole délibérément la
souveraineté de la chine et singer
grossièrement dans les affaires
intérieures de la chine pays où le
gouvernement et le peuple chinois ne
resterons jamais les bras croisés face à
la provocation publique du président du
sénat tchèque et aux forces
antichinoises qui se trouve derrière lui
ils doivent payer un lourd tribut pour
leur comportement et pour leur
opportunisme politique
shenzhen indien ce n'est pas la première
fois que les relations entre pékin et
prague se ternissent en octobre 2019
le maire de la capitale tchèque avait
annulé un accord de jumelage avec pékin
pour protester contre la politique
chinoise
à la place la capitale tchèque avait
préféré taipei la capitale de taïwan
[Applaudissements]